j'ai un gros gros truc à t'annoncer un
projet que j'ai hyper hâte de te faire
découvrir laisse-moi te raconter ça au
cœur de l'été 2022 don les très fond
d'un dieu mystérieux où nul être humain
n'a jamais pénétré une lueur un souffle
de vie un germe prend for secrètement
couvé à l'abri des regards par des
créatures d'un autre monde l'entité
divine prend vie lentement sous les yeux
incrédules de ses chaperons l'incroyable
se produit elle n'est pas une elle est
deux désormais le temps de son règne
approche elle s'apprête à sur révélé aux
yeux du monde à tes yeux émerveillé par
sa double splendeur qui est-elle
qu'est-elle Arvet qu'est-elle ce que je
suis sur le point de te révélé va
changer ta vie à jamais car je t'annonce
aujourd'hui l'avènement de non je te dis
pas pas tout de suite voilà ce qu'on va
faire tu vas essayer de deviner je t'ai
mis plein de petits indices subliminaux
dans cette vidéo donc dis-moi à quoi tu
penses dans les commentaires et moi je
reviens ici demain pour te révéler le
grand secret